this is a production of Cornell
University so I first want to and I did
this yesterday but I'll do this today
again thank you so much the students
like I've been on both sides of now I've
been on both sides of both inviting
people as grad students as a committee
and then it's awesome to be invited by
people you know it's uh
we do this job and we toil away
sometimes and then it's nice to know
that at some level like people people
recognize you so that's awesome
yeah so the talk I'll give today is
completely different than the talk I
gave yesterday what I like to do in my
lab is focus on a broader variety of
topics I'm just a naturally curious
person and I like bacteria and so
luckily bacteria do pretty much
everything in the world and so there's a
ton of topics to dive into the topic
I'll talk about today was something that
I really started probably my third or
second or third year having a lab and it
really just blossomed from there we've
got some really good people at Arizona
that contribute greatly and kind of
drive this project in a lot of ways to
you that I'll acknowledge now so Betsy
Arnold is awesome collaborator Rachel
gallery is an awesome collaborator and
they're fully involved in this as well
so I I can't take any personal credit
it's it's we work really well together
as a team so I just want to say that up
front and I'll acknowledge Rachel and
Betsy at the end as well all right so my
talk today is going to be on a symbiosis
though or maybe assembly else's
interaction at least that I had no clue
existed until I really started my lab so
I was very focused on Pseudomonas
syringae and then started reading papers
and once you start reading more broadly
and you have some time to read more
broadly
it opens your eyes into a variety of
different ways that interactions can
happen to begin though and as a just to
one the room here to a little bit I'm
gonna talk about a horrible human
pathogen outbreak that happened in about
1976 so in 1976 there was a convention
of American Legion folk in Philadelphia
and so this convention that takes place
and I was during the summer I think of
the Spanish flu or one of the flus that
came through and so people went to the
convention a lot of people got sick and
some people died from this convention
there is
mystery as to what the actual cause of
this pathogenicity was where this where
this infection came from turns out that
after a bunch of Epidemiology and some
microbiology and some really cool
genetics work the convention errs that
the American Legion folk we're actually
infected by a strain of Legionella which
is now called legion now it was called
something different back then it's
Legionella cause American Legion
convention Legionella has a pretty
interesting life cycle where it'll just
kind of grow in human environments
because there's amoeba in human
environments and so that uni but really
like the water the Legionella can get
into amoeba kind of survives
intracellularly an amoeba and always
well and good
nothing is involving human pathogenicity
there and everything is kind of hunky
dory the problem is that amoeba look a
lot like someone human immune cells and
so because Legionella has evolved to
infect amoeba it's also really good and
in fact the human immune cells certain
types of human immune cells like matric
macrophage and so what we think happened
is that a lot of different bacteria can
evolve to live inside of a variety of
different eukaryotic microorganisms like
amoeba sometimes we get the secondary
spillover into things like human
pathogen acity potentially things like
plant pathogen nesting so just setting
the stage here there's a lot of
precedent for some work in some systems
showing that bacteria can really
proliferate and survive well in a
variety of different eukaryotic microbes
the Legionella system in the amoeba
system is actually amoeba or basically
used as an analogue of macrophage now a
lot of different labs in the genetics
actually works out pretty well so
there's paper showing you know amoeba
survival Dictyostelium ends up being a
good model system for this as well and
as some labs here have shown as well and
contributing greatly to this is not
limited just to just protists or other
single side eukaryotes it seems like
this is a more widespread phenomenon
where there's a lot of microscopic
eukaryotes that can be infected by or at
least hosts different types of bacteria
I really started this project because so
I started in about 2012 2013 when the
microbiome wave was happening and
everybody's microbiome was getting
sequenced and the joke used to be that
when I made the slide there was the
only thing that didn't have a microbiome
was hotter now there's an otter
microbiome even so there's microbiomes
for everything and there's a variety of
system where it's been shown that i'm at
least at the level of plus or minus
bacteria and this seems to affect
development physiology across a variety
of different eukaryotes what I want to
focus on though is that there's been a
good legacy of at some level at some
very specific level investigating
interactions between bacteria and fungi
so you know I when I started my lab and
when I was starting reading papers I
didn't have a good appreciation that
fungi actually hosted a microbiome um
but once I started digging in it kind of
makes sense like lichens are well known
I'm likings are effectively a fungal
microbiome um there's a pirkled area
rise like Seneca system and then kind of
datas lemare back herb
I'm not the greatest fan of bacterial
nomenclature but basically there's a
another candidate that can be in a
variety of micro mycorrhizal fungi
there's other systems where these other
very specialized it seems bacteria have
evolved to intimately interact with
their fungal hosts they seem to be
vertically inherited they seem to be
there's some certain genomic properties
there that actually contribute to the
symbiosis and so there's this legacy of
at least at very specialized levels
understanding that bacteria can interact
with fungi can be intra Highfill inside
a fungi and can manipulate fungal
behavior and physiology but again when I
started I didn't have this appreciation
and I think hopefully I've contributed
to expanding this this theme throughout
a variety of different systems so this
work really started the work I'll talk
about today really started about 2013 I
emailed Betsy Arnold I read a paper it
might have been Teresa's paper it might
have been a different paper or using the
same system where I read a paper showing
that type 3 secretion was involved in
this pirkled area I was like Seneca
system and so I was coming from Jeff
Daniels lab working on type 3 secretion
of Pseudomonas syringae I saw hay type 3
secretion in bacteria maybe I can jump
into the system maybe I can figure out
some stuff with the factors and then
type risa creation in fungal hosts i'm
email email betsy Arlen said hey is
there any way we can team up and
actually work on this and she said ah I
got a system for you like let's not
working
a lot of people who working on the
pirkled area let's work on this other
completely different system that that we
have no clue what they make of it but I
think there's something there I'm like
all right like fair game let's go for it
and so all of this work just and started
with an email and I kind of went from
there so we'll talk about today builds
off of Betsy Arnold's work and Betsy
Arnold's a variety people that's this
lab where they identified in a variety
of different bacteria they can actually
interact pretty intimately um and in an
end a Highfill way with a variety of
fungal endophyte so I'll talk about
today I'll just give you an overview of
this system kind of tell you a little
bit about the background on the
diversity of this then I'll talk about
my role in and how my questions interact
with this system and so here's the
overview a native New Yorker so I'm not
used to microphones I just kind of
scream at people but I so with the
overview I'll talk a little bit about
bacterial assembly on some fungi and
kind of Betsy's story working into this
and then I'll start to get to the
nitty-gritty of it so if we know that
there's bacteria inside of high P we can
ask questions like you know do they
alter fungal phenotypes is there any way
that we can control this symbiosis and
maybe engineer it in different ways what
are the bacteria get out of this
partnership can we do genetics is there
a type 3 secretion see all these
questions about interactions that really
I've come to you from the plant
pathology side but I'm really just
curious about how these interactions
evolve what kinds of genetic structures
these interactions and how going forward
and how we can predict and manipulate
these interactions maybe for the benefit
of agriculture or you know we're never
gonna feed 9 billion people but we can
we can feed at least a couple more I
think so an overview bacterial semi
ounce of fungi I'm not gonna show many
pictures of plants I have a hard time
growing plants and I'm not I don't have
a green thumb I'm in a plant sciences
department but I can't grow plants very
well so what I can do is I can isolate
bacteria from
a variety of different plants so a lot
of what I'll talk about today takes
place in the Compu have to imagine caps
on imagine it's all taking place in the
context of plants like this so the
splatted cladius orientalis basically a
juniper juniper berry kind of plant the
needles on it are like pine needles
they're kind of coniferous and tough all
of the fungi that I'll talk about
for the most part of today where I
saluted from this type of plant and all
the bacterial talked about from this
fungi are theoretically living either on
the needles or inside of the fungi
inside of the Russian doll that is this
whole system if you look across
different plant species I don't know if
there's an exception to this I'm pretty
sure there's not but if you sample all
plant species will contain endophytes at
some level I'm a lot of them have fungal
into fights and these fungal endophyte
contributes to different plant behaviors
some of them have been shown to
influence pan plant physiology and
immune systems they make them a little
bit more resistant to pathogens some of
them are potentially pathogens you know
that every plant species seems to have
its own fungal endophyte s-- at some
level these Juniper species and Betsy
has shown this throughout a variety of
plants throughout the world these tend
to be covered in fungal endophyte so if
you just sample a little bit of a pine
needle you'll find a ton diversity in
terms of the fungi that actually live
there or live in the roots or live in
the stems or live in the soil around the
fungi or around the plant the fungi I'll
focus on for about three-quarters of the
talk today are gonna be N 2 fights of
leaves and so they're found within
leaves and that's kind of what Betsy
specialized on going around the world
fungal endophyte some leaves have a kind
of an interesting life cycle when you
think about it so a lot of these are
found so when the leaf emergence it
tends to be sterile or in a lot of
plants the fungi we think through scores
and other ways get up and in fact the
leaves as they emerge and you get a
really high level of diversity within a
leaf over a short amount of time so you
know within a couple weeks you get a lot
of different diverse types of fungi
they're actually within these leaves
eventually though you know spoiler alert
everything dies so eventually the leaf
is going to die it's gonna fall to the
ground and a lot of these fungi end up
being able to switch their lifecycle to
become saprotrophic so
they go from endophytes to stop or truce
and we don't really understand that
transition it's a kind of a cool
transition if the same fungi are doing
both roles so eventually the saboteurs
break down things in the soil they spoil
later or you know some other mysterious
ways they might get up into the air
again
but those spores get up in the air which
we think then in fact those newly
emerging lead so really is kind of a
Lion King circle of life thing I have a
four year old so I speak in Disney
movies a lot of time so I apologize for
that very well
frozen yea I've taken all the frozen
references out but all right so what
Betsy shown in this is where this is
where I come into the story so I came in
right after this paper was published
Betsy and her former grad student /
postdoc Michelle Othman had showed in a
variety of these fungal and of fights
that they seemed to contain bacterial
symbionts and though it's a cool story
to understand I this is the story I tell
I think Betsy tells it slightly
different but I like my version better
so Betsy is very very detailed and very
specific and how she curates things and
cleans things and her and Michelle were
isolating a bunch of these fungi from
around the world we're preparing sterile
isolates of it and putting them in water
auger or water or water pushers and so
over time they just had this massive
collection of water vouchers of fungi
which is basically just fungi in water
every once in a while they would see
bacterial contaminants pop up in the
water auger and they're like oh there's
you know we got a autoclave things
better than we got to clean things
better and be really really vehement and
getting these bacteria out because they
thought they were contaminants when they
start to look back at the data the same
contaminants are popping up in the same
fungal cultures and no matter how well
they cleaned they would get these same
contaminants coming up again and again
and again then Betsy Michelle maybe
they're actually in the fungi and
they're just popping out at certain
levels um and then you know they did
some fish these are fish papers from a
16s fish from a couple of different
fungi but basically these dots are
bacteria that seem to be within the
hyphy of a variety of different fungi so
again this is where I come in
what Betsy Michelle were able to do was
just you know
Tina's PCR and amplify using amplicon
sequencing a variety of these spectral
sequences from the fungi they built a
tree the tree is gonna happen in a
second in a couple of slides but I will
get to that so we think and this is kind
of how Betsy's whole isolation scheme so
we think what happens is that there's
just fungi and bacteria inside of those
fungi inside of leaves and things like
platic lattice we can plate out the
fungi and then they look like normal
fungi we just plate them out on just
normal augur bacteria don't emerge out
at this point so this is this plus
represents there's a bacteria inside of
there but when you actually grow them on
plates you don't see the bacteria
popping out it took a while to figure
this out but it's not just that you can
put the fungi and have the bacteria pop
out what you have to do is stress out
the fungi and bacteria a little bit and
so what we would do and again this is
sometimes you do indirect experiments
that end up showing you how to the way
so it turns out you need to heat shock
you sponge out a little bit and then you
get the bacteria and a dotting out and
growing out from the fungi so we can
take these clean fungal isolates heat
shock them a little bit and then we get
what we now call ehb I'm just kind of
emerging out now I think there's a tree
right so Betsy and Michelle sequence
both without culturing and them with
culturing some of them variety of these
different bacterial types that they
found inside of these fungal endophyte
s' this is a tree representing a lot of
the diversity I found I like this tree
because it represents a couple of things
that I like to frame this question went
first off this is the tree that shows a
huge diversity of bacteria so we have
gram positives a proteobacteria there's
a lot of protein bacteria there and then
even within the proteobacteria some
other more specialized ones point I want
to make is there's gram positives and
gram negatives in this tree it's not
like there's a truly specialized you
know pattern that we're seeing yet
second thing I want to point out in this
yellow box that represents the pirkled
area if you look at a variety of
different bacteria interacting with
fungal systems more often than not it's
going to be a pirkled area that you see
and so this yellow box represents the
pirkled area in a variety of different
forms even that candidate s lemare
bacter again I'm I get in I get an
arguments with nomenclatural people go
mirror back there kind of is the pirkled
area
clayed like it's just a little bit more
specialized in Alaska Larry backers up
there Buerkle Derry is there there's
another pirkled area and a forum on the
different played I'm so that yellow box
effectively represents the 80% of what
was known before Betsy published this
paper showing and a bacterial diversity
inside of fungi what Betsy was able to
show him what Betsy Michelle showed or
in this blue box these are all isolates
from different fungal sequencing
isolates from different fungi that they
had you'll notice and we have some
Buerkle Darius I didn't I didn't put
overlay on that but a lot of these other
types of bacteria or not they were never
really shown to be associated with fungi
before and there's a huge diversity we
have gram positives a bunch of alpha
Proteobacteria a bunch of gamma beta all
over the place the nice part about these
is that a lot of these bacteria end up
being highly culturable very easily
culturable and so it as a bacteriologist
i kind of screamed out to me like i can
actually do genetics and grow these
things and manipulate them it seemed
like an awesome system to actually jump
into so that's step one a lot of
different diversity within bacteria
within fungi when we actually started
looking at the phylogenetic diversity
and matching up you know which bacteria
was found in which fungal hosts what you
would see was that within and these
boxes just represent clades of bacteria
within the blue box and within the red
box these are different isolates of
bacteria from fungi these are the fungal
names what I want you to take away from
this is that we find very similar
bacteria in very different fungal hosts
all within kind of the the ascomycete
but very different fungal hosts and so
we've even now got nearly identical
strains there's basically there's no
snips between strain no no single
nucleotide polymorphisms between the
bacterial strains found within different
classes of ascomycete so we think that
speaks that there's maybe these are
being horizontally transferred across
strains pretty frequently and pretty
readily versus the vertical inherence
that you may see with things like the
burgled area or the the gloomier back
here are the molecules isolates so we
see this in a variety different way so
here's these are the ones the blue box
is the ones like kind of focused on
going forward these are ludia bacter
they're kind of Xanthomonas die yellow
blue tobacker things yeah
proteobacteria these ones are more
enteric so you get it or wynia panto
eeeh other things like that i'm but
again we we find her winnie a very
similar winnie strains across very
different fungal host so we think
they're being horizontally transferred
and then even within the same fungal
host we can find multiple isolates that
are divergent so in this case we have a
fungal host as the lodi abscess that
actually has we think in this case we
have one that's the pestle OD abscess
that has Lutie bacteria and a Rhizobium
this one's I'm showing a pestle OD
abscess with in erwinia I'm Anna Louie
Becker there can be multiple bacterial
types within the same fungal host
spatially we don't have it quite worked
out yet but it seems like we've found
about I think 12 different 16s sequences
within a - Mac a bacteria so it seems
like there's potential there for quite a
high amount of diversity relative to
what we would have imagined originally
think again we don't quite know how
they're spatially structure it seems
like there is some spatial structure to
where they're found but we can find
multiple bacterial isolates within the
same fungus and I think that's
interesting going forward kind of
thinking about what that does in terms
of combinations far majority of them
though just have kind of one isolate
that we can see up to 12 in some cases
though so we can isolate a lot of these
are culturable and if they're culturable
that means we can do a lot of
interesting bacterial genetics and other
associations between them so we can also
clear the fungi of the bacteria and so
it was pretty easy to kind of figure
this out and then other labs have shown
this before so if we grow these fungi on
a cocktail of antibiotics and in some
cases this doesn't even work but if we
grow them on a cocktail of antibiotics
eventually we can get clean fungi
without bacterial symbiosis we verify
this through fish we verify it through
PCR and just through microscopy they
seem to be pretty clean we can get AZ
Nakai Slits AZ nick just meaning no
bacteria colonizing them a fungi
if we can culture the bacteria and we
can culture the fungal host seems like
we should be able to try to figure out
how to put them back together as well
took us a while probably two years to
figure out the tricks with this because
they wouldn't take for a lot of the
times but we finally figured out that if
we grow the fungus and bacteria
separately
mix them together in minimal media in
some cases the trick was actually
growing them in middle media and giving
them a little bit of a starvation
environment seems like the bacteria tend
to go back into the fungi a lot more
under those conditions and so it ends up
being pretty easy to reassociate these
if you have the right conditions we just
mix them together and liquid and they
can you just go back together it's kind
of nice so we can reassociate bacteria
with fungi and how do we prove this well
we prove it through again through PCR
through just culturing if you grow if
you take this mixed culture and just put
it on a plate you don't see any bacteria
growing on the outside so we think
they're inside but then you can do
things like microscopy so what I'm going
to show you in this case is a we've been
able to label with TD tomato a
fluorophore we've labeled with Louie
backer with that fluorophore
in this case we just did some microscopy
showing fluorescence of that so here is
going to be look here for the rien occu
lated bacterial isolate this is just
going to be a sterile I showing there's
no background fluorescence so here's TD
tomato showing up kind of along the
lines of the hyphy the reviewers
tolerated this but they weren't quite
happy with this because I mean you can
kind of they look like they're inside
the hyphy but they might just all be
attached to the hyphy and kind of
fluoresce even a few different planes
like we got it published but we weren't
quite happy with this so and it took us
a while but since we had that
fluorescent isolated bacteria I mean
then we could do confocal microscopy I
was using my own computer I have a fancy
illustration of showing this it's just
not going to be as dramatic as I wanted
to be but here's the confocal picture I
could do Z Sachs
if you labeled a TD tomato there's a
bacteria in the little red spots the
blue on the outside is Kalka floor so
that basically stains chitin and it's
things the fungal walls blue so if we do
a Z stack through this you can basically
definitely tell that there's fluorescent
bacteria inside of the - that's not just
the bound to the outside I'm again I
just imagine a little bit you know this
part turns blue and then the red goes
away and then the blue comes back up my
other side video um anyway kind of sad
when you spend a lot of time trying to
get this one done anyway
anyway whether those are if y'all were
reviewing that paper like we finally
have the confocal pictures and I truly
at least in this case truly believe
that we can we can read inoculate and
they get back inside the hyphy as you'll
see we don't think that they're super
dense inside the hyphy and even in a lot
of cases we think they might go into
some like stasis kind of a not really
growing actively state but they're at
least growing actively enough to make
that TD tomato for for that's that's
good alright last thing I want to show
you and this is another trick again this
a lot of this talking's at being a lot
of the tricks I learned along the way to
try to figure out how to actually do
this but the other thing I wanted to do
was try to measure can we figure out a
way to reassociate these bacteria where
I can almost you know not in a
high-throughput way but in a much more
systematic way go through and understand
host ratings so my background is in
evolutionary biology I want to
understand the genetics and and how host
range of Olives across a variety of
hosts that's kind of why I want to see
the monitoring and what I'd like to go
to now I'm with this fungal system I
want to understand you know how does
host Ranger Bob is their host range I
mean that's that's still a question is
there a host range and then what is the
genetics in your line so to get to that
point I need to set up a pretty
straightforward host train jury
Association system my background was in
Gila kaback you're in grad school and we
had a trick to actually select for
intracellular you know just using tissue
culture and human tissue culture cells
what you could do with he'll go back
here is if you took tissue culture cells
mixed in he like a backer putting
gentamicin I'm jeanna Meissen ends up
being if you if he targeted right at the
right concentration gentamicin ends up
killing extracellular bacteria but
inside the cell is protected because the
gentamicin doesn't penetrate the
eukaryotic cell walls I was I just took
a shot in the dark but this seems to
work I think the right levels to go with
in the beginning with the bacteria and
the fungi so what I'm showing you here
is the initial this is a liquid
population so this is just bacteria
inoculated into liquid I let this go for
three days again in minimal media so m9
I've got two populations they grow and
this is you know there's multiple
replicates within these populations so
multiple replicates here multiple
replicates here a lot of bacteria and
then what I can do on day four is just
hit them with jenna Meissen at 49 and
grams per microliter
put that in and then measure the
cultural but culturable bacteria that
come out of the supernatant not
measuring the fungi that come out of the
supernatant
after that so here you'll see that in
the no gentamicin treatment they don't
grow anymore they're just kind of their
magenta mice and treatment universally I
get nothing back so either they're being
killed extracellular Lee I'm extra - Lee
or they're just being non culturable but
in this case I think it's a pretty good
selective measure where if I do this I
can at least screw up the outside of the
bacteria outside the fungi at a certain
level where I think it acts as a sieve
to select at some level for ones that
get back inside so I was kind of happy
to see that that actually worked
all right so going forward now I have a
nasty to measure can we take different
bacterial isolates put them back into a
single fungal I slit and see again
primary question here is there something
as a host range is it just everybody
every bacteria that is available gets in
or is there some sort of way that fungi
can select for who gets back in or some
way that bacteria can actively evolve to
get back in alright so the way I'm gonna
do this assay is gonna grow up just like
I showed you in the last case grow up
the bacteria and fungi together in
mineral media add gentamicin for a day
which theoretically either kills or
renders non culturable everything in the
supernatant middle I'll take that fungal
mass which is growing in the liquid
culture clean it out on water auger
again really no nutrients the bacteria
none of these bacteria grow it's just
auger they're not gonna grow on it what
the fungal mass expand and then after
five six seven eight days I'll pick on
the outside growing edge of the fungal
mass I'm again in no case do I see
bacteria actually growing on the plate
and a lot of those comp opal images and
the microscopy images I've shown before
I miss taking place in this in this
plate context too so we've we've done
the controls to show it's not that the
bacteria are just kind of quitting on
the auger plate I think they're actually
in the hyphy here so we're gonna sample
on the edge of the growing hyphy just
like that I'll take a bunch of different
samples per plate this is what I was
just showing this sample was taking four
days five days six days and seven days
after growth but really is there's not
bacteria kind of clear it's truly just
fungal hypha so the data I'll show on
the next slide is just taking these
cores we think plating them out and I've
done this in a bunch of different
replicates I was kind of saddened at the
beginning because every worked was
probably a different bacterial end to
hide
bacteria that I was like oh there's got
to be some differentiation here in a
single fungal house like there's got to
be something when I did this assay they
all seemed to go into the same levels
and they're they're getting we get we
get a lot of bacteria back out of the
single fungal course but all of those
endo Highfill bacteria seem to go in at
the same levels and so there's maybe
there's not a horse range but I've got
my little four other a variety of other
side projects in the lab I like to work
with Pseudomonas that's RI which is just
a big witnessed environmental bacteria
it's naturally transformable so the
genetics is kind of interesting but
that's my baby my lab baby that I try to
work in any experiment that I can I'm so
I took a Louie Becker strain reassociate
with fungal host and then took a
bacterial that Pseudomonas duster.i
strain did the same thing I've reached
the level of associate professor so I'm
I've seen every technological challenge
alright so what you're seeing here is
just a bunch of those fungal hypha cores
this is log CF uses a log scale this is
just a Lutie back your species and again
we get you know 10 to the 5th out per
centimeter so there's a lot of Looby
back to there Pseudomonas that's RI
usually we get back nothing which is
good you know I think there really is
something as a host range in terms of
some bacteria can reassociate and some
can't that's awesome every once in a
while I'll get a little bit of
Pseudomonas that's right coming through
these assays and there's some that get
into the hi-c the reason I don't show
that cleaned up data is because so
there's a number there it's a positive
number in every case where I've followed
up on this there's Lube actor
contamination in the fungal hyphae as
well they just you know you just kind of
cross get it in so whatever so if it's
just us right it doesn't get back in at
all if you mix it a little bit with Lou
do you back you're on the stud sir I can
get back in at a certain level so I
think there's something cool going on
there that I haven't fleshed out yet as
well
so there are qualitative differences and
reassociation capabilities which some
level means there's something like host
range within these bacteria fungi which
again going forward is is kind of
awesome for the way I like to think
about the world and the way I like to
test the world so that's the you know
somebody on some fungi now we can ask
questions now that we can do
reassociation x' and kind of do the
controlled assays we can ask questions
about do these bacteria actually
contribute to to fungal behavior do they
change anything at all
we'll see so we can take this pestle OD
abscess nine one four three ISIL it
naturally infected with lutea bacteria
species I'd I need to I hate bacterial
nomenclature but indigo because they
have to do field trials I'm trying to
actually name this guy because they have
to do that for the USDA and releasing
stuff so this is going to now be called
Louie Becker I think my co business
there's a business this is my co
business for fungal proximity soluti
backer nine 1:43 is isolate comes from
nine one four three
this fungi is naturally infected with
bat yellow blue tea back your bacteria
and we can hear that fungi that fungus
by antibiotic treatments and so that's
that's pretty straightforward and then
we can resynthesize this strain with the
same bacteria and so the data I'll show
you going forward is either they'll be
called natural infected cured or or
resynthesize so just kind of keep those
in your head going forward those are
variety different assays I could show
but I like this one because it kind of
makes makes an interesting point it's
it's somewhat quantifiable and so these
fungal endophyte end up having again
that circle of life lifestyle where they
can be plant growth promoting that can
be degraders hypertrophy and so again
for a variety of reasons we went down
the road of looking at degradation
because in a maybe g so we were we were
interested in quantifying the ability of
fungi to degrade various plant materials
with and without bacterial some ions and
then a i'll show you here is just a
cellulose i say this is congo red binds
to things like cellulose have you put
into play mice to a bunch of different
sugars to but we've kind of ruled those
out as a control this is a fungal mass
growing in the middle and then we're
just going to measure this zoning
this clearing outside of the fungal mass
of the
cellulase whatever it is I'm against we
get Lisi clearing outside of the fungal
masses growth and that's what we're
gonna measure in terms of our
quantitative ability here naturally
infected has a certain amount of
clearing which we've kind of normalized
to a level around one so naturally
affect it as a certain amount of
clearing the cured strain of this nine
one four three we see no clearing that
was kind of a nice qualitative
something's changing in these fungi we
take the bacteria away that clearing
zone goes away which is awesome now
because we can resynthesize we can
actually do the control put the bacteria
back in with the resynthesized that
clearing comes back and so whatever it
is whatever this bacteria is doing it's
affecting the whatever this clearing
zone means in terms of cellulose
clearing and so that's kind of cool
that was our foray into it and we then
were you know again you take a shot in
the dark
alright so this is just a quantitative
assay on a plate why don't we just mix
plants and fungi together and see what
happens I am still amazed that this
works we did stats they're different the
other thing to say is that the bacteria
themselves alluded back here has a
little bit of cellulose activity but
even in transposon mutants like we still
see that clearing zone going out so it's
not the bacteria that's doing it
specifically it's something happening to
the fungus that's leading to that
clearing activity all right so what
about rates of decomposition again I'm
amazed that this works but it works so
what we can do is take plant material
put it in a petri dish and then
inoculate you the with fungus seasoning
fungus or fungus with that nine one four
three strain if we let that go for like
three months which you can actually do
is is way this petri dish over time and
obviously we do it in replicates if you
weigh that over time you can actually
measure like mass loss because it's a
pyro film them but they lose either
through water or co2 or something they
lose mass from this plate so we can
actually measure amounts of degradation
over time just by weighing the petri
dish very non-intuitive graph but the
higher the number here the greater the
mass loss so I apologize for it should
be greater the number the more the
masses lost I'm not a lot of mass is
being lost here but again we've done
this in a bunch of different replicates
and it
the stats worked out as I'll show you so
at a high end we've got three percent
and then and zero and the naturally
affected just that naturally infected
fungus we get about a 2% mass loss over
again two or three months in the cured
fungus we get less and so it's maybe 75%
of the mass loss or so statistically
different again nonparametric stats like
bunch of replicates like this for
whatever reason it works out and then we
can do that recent assistance show you
know does this come back together sure
enough it comes back we can actually
recapitulate that mass loss with the
bacteria so those are numbers those are
stats sometimes it's not the most yeah
sometimes people don't like numbers and
so picture I'm gonna show you next
hopefully convinces you that something
else is happening here because I'm going
to show you pictures of those various
treatments at least representative
pictures from those treatments here's
the control with nothing on so that's
just the mass loss of you know no fungus
growing over time here's a different
fungus but the same kind of a treatments
this is a zenok fungus again after three
months hasn't broken down that plant
material at all that fungus plus
bacteria you get a nice mat that's
actually breaking down stuff like
visually and this this happens really
repeatedly so it's you know we have
numbers but that's pretty striking like
you get growth and not growth so even
though it's like if you know 1%
difference you're measuring degradation
so it's kind of hard over time I believe
it I think something's happening here I
think something's cool happening here I
don't have the data following up on this
but we basically just finished so the
next step with this was to take you know
plus and minus bacteria fungus put it in
a litter box or a litter bag and stick
it in the ground for three months same
kinds of trends happen so that the
degradation difference happens in the
ground in Arizona in January which is
weird because it's not and I'm amazed
that it works but it works we get the
same difference in degradation over time
so I think this might be ecologically
relevant I'm really curious going
forward in the future like with the
genetics of all this because I think I
think there's a lot of questions here
all right so yeah so that's the the
behaviors I think things are changing
Betsy has some other stories showing
that plant group oxen production plant
hormone production synthesis by the
fungus kind of changes with the bacteria
- I think there's a story here going
forward where that partnership actually
matters for a variety of different
fungal traits then we can ask what are
the bacteria get out of this partnership
what's going on here at some level it
might be things like antibiotic
resistance where if they hide out my fee
I actually already showed you that there
they can tolerate gentamicin at a
certain level but there might be
something else there so with this
question I'm gonna focus on that Lutie
bacter mycav businness species that I'm
focused on before because I noticed
something weird with that species
compared to a bunch of the other
bacteria I was working with and if you
actually look through we had a bunch of
these ludia backers pop up in a variety
of different fungi and it just seemed
like there was something there that was
different with the Louie backers versus
the other bacteria and if you do if you
look at Philo sphere
you know just microbiome samples you
don't get a lot of Lutie backyard
they're not really there we see them a
lot in the sunshine so I thought maybe
this is a something to dig in and
actually make the system out of I was
just growing actually the the story
behind this is that I have my Lutie
backer and I teach microbials you know
this course every year and we do a
transposon mutagenesis experiment with
the students I just assume that things
would behave and so I a new Lutie back
your grew an lb media I'm like well we
can do them throw it on lb make
transpose I mutants and then we can look
for things like oxygen ease so I set up
this whole lab with you know 80 by 80
undergraduates and they were looking for
us and it turns out Louie Becker doesn't
grow and I media alone so it's kind of
naturally an oxygen
anyway test before you set up labs 480
people test that it works first before
jumping in but that led me to that stood
this so I knew that Lydia batcher so
from that lab I knew at getting grow
mineral media um but I knew that if we
put Lutie backer in with the fungus in
liquid mineral media I would get
bacteria in the super date like you
would get cloudy you would see the
bacteria growing and so I just kind of
recapitulated that experiment here this
is just a growth curve in liquid culture
in m9 mineral media here's Lou do you
back your without fungus in the
triangles really doesn't grow it does it
just kind of stays static
with the fungus
put the fungus in there Louie bacter in
the supernatant the density goes up over
time and so the fungus is able to
produce something that feeds the loonie
back to something its mission typically
we would interpret this as maybe there
is an oscar the-- maybe there's some
pathway in the fungus in the bacteria
that's missing an amino acid production
pathway or something that's kind of a
typical assumption you would make they
stopped at this result so what I did was
I went back in tested every amino acid
individually with the Lutie back to see
if they could compliment growing within
that liquid culture and I found that it
was not a simple story but it's a cool
story so the there was two amino acids
that could complement Ludi back to your
growth in liquid culture in m9 cysteine
Ameth I mean and so what are those
having calm they're the only
sulfur-containing amino acids so it
turns out that if you add swapper
containing amino acids to m9 who do you
badger can grow so I started digging
around in genomes trying to figure out
what's actually going on here cuz Lou do
you backed your it's like a Xanthomonas
it's a proteobacteria should be able to
grow on sulfate because all the mineral
media's are derived from e.coli and they
all have magnesium sulfate in them as a
sulfur source so what's going on with
moody back here here's just a from a
different paper showing again across
proteobacteria like they all transport
sulfate they're all really good at
acquiring sulfate from sulfur from
sulfate when you look at Ludi bacter
it's actually missing all the sulfate
transporters and kind of all the
associated genes as well so it's weird
for protein bacteria because it can't
use sulfate as a sulfur source um I
don't know what it's using in terms of
growth with the fungus but I think this
might be you know hand-waving Lee
potentially a step towards more of a
specialization going forward in the
future with the fungus that's I think
that's a cool you know early stage is
maybe a more specialization that we're
seeing because it's it's just weird that
they don't use sulfate I should say in a
couple of marine systems you do see a
eukaryotic microbe supplying sulfur
through DMS P to some of its microbes
that actually grow on it so there's
precedent with sulfur transport between
eukaryotes and microbes as well alright
last thing I'm going to talk about is
you know how do we use this data going
forward what can we do going forward in
terms of potentially manipulating
microbe ions may be making the world a
little bit of a better place and we
always like to write that in grants but
I'm cynical but well we'll see going
forward
so how can we actually make a difference
and engineer some microbiomes
the thing about plant microbiomes is
that they're really hard to change once
they get established bacteria coming
from the outside environment they're
coming from everywhere the soil the air
the vectors everywhere else and so once
the plant is there it's really hard to
change the microbiome that's actually on
the plant so when you start thinking
about this there's there's a couple
places where I think you can really
manipulate who's growing on the plants
and how you can change the physiology of
the plants going forward with the
microbiome I just like to slot I drew a
tree and I always like to show the tree
that I draw so there's a little fly
you got you got the small victories in
science so what I'm gonna focus on is so
the microbiome is hard to change once
it's established but at the beginning
maybe we can change it a little bit and
kind of skew it towards manipulating
physiology a plant hosts in a way that
might be beneficial going forward so I
think we can do this at the stage of the
seed because the seed typically is
colonized by a few if any fungi and
bacteria and we might be able to make a
difference if we actually do things like
coat seeds and that might affect
germination rates or survival of season
different environments so I had a grad
student in a Hoover Oda EPA fellowship
to go down to I think Panama which was
awesome because he's like I'm going to
Pat him oughta do something go for it
dude um so he had a fun time down there
but what he was doing was investigating
seed borne fungi and their bacterial syn
myosin and can we can we manipulate the
the bacteria some ions of these seed
borne fungi to manipulate germination
rates the plant that I'm gonna show you
data from was Cecropia this ends up
being one of these pioneer species in
the Panamanian rainforest or what a
tropics I one of those one of those hot
places that's not for now so sorry
so Cecropia is one of these pioneer
trees where it's really limited by
sunlight so in the rainforest you get
holes when trees fall down and then
these pioneer trees pop up really
quickly and it's kind of a life strategy
thing so Cecropia is one of those trees
that really pops up to capitalize on
those those open spaces the season of
being huge and they end up being pretty
easy to collect and so that's why Justin
actually went with these seeds the assay
he did was basically two just like
before or the
isolate fungi grow the fungi and
antibiotics and know and try to cure
them up the bacteria and then he had a
bunch of different paradise lots of
bacteria and no bacteria fungi isolated
from Cecropia seeds yeah say he then did
was in like 50 days in a shade house in
Panama he would take all of these great
grad students now great post doc doing
CRISPR stuff but Justin Schafer's
awesome if you guys have a chance to
hire him in the future
hire him he's awesome that's my plug for
Justin um alright so I'm no clue whether
he applies anywhere but nonetheless so
what Justin would do is you would take
these individual seeds put them in a
dish cover the dish for like 50 days and
then go back and measure the amount of
germination so you can see here some of
these seeds germinate some don't so you
measure the percentage of germination of
these plates both with bacteria in fungi
and just with fungi alone without
bacteria on both of these plates or have
fungi on them and the fungi head back to
here you can see there's a very
different fungi very different
strategies here but it's just gonna
measure germination rates in Cecropia
seeds going through timeline you know
not the best genetically controlled
experiment but you do what you can in
the fungal rain and the rainforest out
of Panama what he found was in a variety
different cases with different fungi and
we know kind of who the players are and
all of this you can get different
results depending on which which
partnership you actually choose so in
some cases in a majority of cases we
actually saw fungi with bacteria had
more germination of the seeds than just
lungile own with those seeds so this is
showing you know minus and plus minus is
without bacteria plus is with bacteria
and then this is just again completely
non-intuitive graph sorry about that but
this is the germination rate so this is
low germination this is higher
germination low germination higher
germination low higher so bacteria plus
the fungi seem to affect the germination
rate of those seeds in that shade house
so that's some cases other cases we get
no effect so that's kind of a good
control and in some cases we actually
get a negative effect and so whether you
want to call us a pathogen or not it's
know you get into the semantics about a
culpas here but in this case we've got a
fungus alone effects termination of a
certain rate fungus bacteria lowers the
germination rate so again maybe a
pathogen maybe again it's a kind of
sticky situations there and try to find
them
all right so wrapping up so the
conclusions here so I've hopefully
showing you at least at some level that
many indefinite fungi contain bacteria
in a facultative bacteria in a way that
we don't quite understand that their
specialization or not but I think that
they're they're pretty prevalent in
terms of who's out there and who's
associating with you
Louie bacter strains can modulate at
some level the ability of fungi to
degrade plant material both in very
synthetic contexts but also we think in
very natural contexts blue do you back
your seems to require organic sulfur
maybe from amino acids maybe from some
other weird things you know plants have
like sulfur lipids and stuff that might
get processed there's a variety of
different organic sulfur sources that
could be used by the booty back here I'm
in the fungi in the plants but it can't
use sulfate so that's kind of weird
compared other Proteobacteria and then
lastly that last slide and a Highfill
bacteria can influence fungal
interactions with plants in a variety of
different ways then the other data that
I haven't shown that we haven't really
processed yet but it's taken us like
five years to do this but we finally
have like transcriptomes and dual
transcript thumbs and do them at a
Balaam's for all these and you know
expression changes when you put bacteria
with fungus and there's what seems to be
the the theme and this is a dose
breakers work that I'll mention in a
second but the theme here is that a lot
of these fungi have but we're thought to
be silent secondary metabolite clusters
you mix them with these bacteria and
some of those secondary metabolite
clusters get turned on then we can see
the metabolites actually showing up so I
think there's a another cool story
they're showing about how these
associations actually matter so with
that I all of this work like none of it
would have happened without a simple
email to Betsy and then Betsy's she's a
force of nature
I bring the bacterial side she brings
the fungal side it works really well
together I'm Kayla Aaron was a grad
student who did a lot of those early
reassociation work kind of figuring out
how to make it work justin was the guy
that got to go to Panama for a couple
months on the government dollar and then
Jos breaker as a postdoc now in Betsy's
lab again Joe is applying for jobs so
he's doing the transcriptome abalone
stuff my lab couple of technicians and
uh Kevin Hockett helped out with this
project Kevin's now a p.i at Penn State
and then a bunch of other postdocs and
undergraduates and a variety of people
have contributed over the years to this
works
I I could just get to be the lowly back
heel geneticist a huge team of awesome
people so thank you very much and thank
you for the invite yeah yeah can I talk
about hosts ranges for the better so at
a certain level the patterns don't make
sense Mia so every bacteria that I get
out of them to FIDIC fungi seems to be
able to go back into that 9 1 4 3
isolate as we mentioned before so the
other thing that I'm trying to chew in
on this and it just finally I think I
have an isolate so the pestalozzi
opposites ends up being a mess to work
with genetically engineering
so I've always tried to get the system
working in or aspera none of those endo
FIDIC and no - bacteria go into
Neurospora using the assays that I've
defined but now I found one that I can
reassociate with nos bruh and I think
gets into the - or aspirin so at some
level like the pestle OD abscess can
pick Pseudomonas versus yeah no -
bacteria Nawroz pura doesn't like any of
those but there's another one that gets
in their roster so I think there's
something happening there but I don't
know the phylogenetic patterns of what's
actually going on there as we've talked
about like I'm I I want that neuron
system to work cuz I can do so much cool
stuff in that if I can get it to work no
yeah that has bacteria so do any do you
ever find any that don't have the
bacterial nature um so yeah so there's
we've done some some sampling and
Justins than a lot more sampling in the
seed associated ones but if you look
somewhere between 60 and 70 percent
seemed to have bacteria and then about
30 percent don't um it's not a
phylogenetic thing it really is like you
know some haven't some don't and then
even within the - Matt's kind of like
citrus greening where it's like there's
some in some places but not in the other
places the way I like to contextualise
this and maybe what what is happening is
there's a lot of work on them in the
microbiome world there's a lot
plus and minus bacteria and mice and I
take it bacteria away from mouse you
compared to the nota biotic mice they're
different um so that's completely
synthetic I think in the fungal world we
really do have this natural analog of
plus and minus bacteria at certain
spatial parts of the hyphy and that
might matter for differences in
physiology throughout the eye if you
really it maybe not at the specialized
level of interaction but maybe plus and
minus bacteria and then that changes
what the fungi are doing even within a
single you know mass yeah so there's
there's definitely a bunch of there's a
much height be out there that don't have
bacteria and then that we can see or
that we can piece you are anything so
that might be something that's going on
okay this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu